Speaker 1: Rudy Giuliani humiliated lawyer
Rudy Giuliani, who once represented failed.
Former President Donald Trump is now saying very
clearly and very directly Trump would tell me,
takes top secret files home with you. Take them
home with you, Rudy. We don't even know if Rudy
had a clearance to look at those files. Never
mind. He obviously should not be taking them
home. Business Insider reports Rudy Giuliani
says Trump once told him to take top secret
documents home. Giuliani said the incident
occurred just after Trump became president
when he was working at Mar a Lago. Giuliani
said he did not bring the documents home.
Giuliani says he was at Mar a Lago working on,
quote, vetting some, quote, very rich people,
specifically going through their tax returns
for Trump. This happened right after Trump
became president, quote, When I was his lawyer, I
mean, there was a period of time I was there like
ten straight days, Giuliani said on the Sunday
episode of the W ABC 77 radio show Uncovering
the Truth with Rudy Giuliani and Dr. Maria Ryan.
I didn't take listen to this. This is my training
on top secret. I didn't take him out of Mar a Lago
describing how he handled the documents. He told
me, oh, take them home with you, Giuliani said of
Trump. I'm not going to take Wilbur Ross his tax
returns home with me. I could misplace them. I you
know, I never, ever, ever, ever, ever knowingly
and I never got caught. But I don't remember
ever taking a document, Giuliani said. He said
he would put the documents in a small safe at his
desk in Mar a Lago to be worked on the next day.
Giuliani also said top secret files are, quote,
very, very strange. The way they are put together
and often are very small, but they contain a
lot of information. Giuliani and a spokesman
for Trump did not immediately respond. Now,
put aside just for a moment, take them home.
There is a broader question. Did Rudy Giuliani
have a security clearance throughout his time
working in this capacity to even look at those
documents? And the answer is we don't know.
Back in 2019, Maguire says he doesn't know if
Giuliani had a security clearance. Acting Director
of National Intelligence Joseph Maguire said he
doesn't know whether Trump's personal lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani, has security clearance. Amid
questions over his role in Trump's interactions
with Ukraine's president. Maguire said I don't
know whether or not Giuliani has a security
clearance. This came in response to questioning
from Congressman Mike Quigley about whether it
was improper for Giuliani to be involved in Trump
asking Zelensky to investigate Biden and Hunter.
Multiple reports about that. If you go back to
that point in time on MSNBC, acting DNI doesn't
know if Rudy Giuliani had a security clearance,
even if you have a clearance. It's not like you
can just be waltzing in and out and looking
through files. And I think this is one of the
important details. It should be added just sort of
generally when we have these conversations about
classified documents, security clearances, etc..
The having the clearance is necessary to be able
to look at a lot of different documents and files,
but it is not sufficient. And what's important to
understand and a couple of lawyers wrote to me
about this and explained it to me clearly this
the clearance is required to even be eligible
to look at a lot of the stuff. But in addition,
you have to have some connection to it.
You have to have some need to know. There
has to be some reason, some nexus as to
why you and the document are coming into
contact. And with a lot of these issues, it
seems as though there are some that believe
if you have a particular clearance, you can
just willy nilly on a whim at any point in
time grab the files that are in line with that
security clearance, with no actual operational
or working connection to them. You can't at least
not the way the rules and the law is written. Now,
what was going on in Trump's White House? We
know that with Jared Kushner and some others,
they didn't even really they weren't supposed
to get security clearances. But then there was
like an override done and they got them anyway.
We covered it years ago. We really don't know
what the standard operating procedure was, but
Trump telling Rudy just take documents home,
is very much in line with what we have seen and
learned about over those many years. Are any of
these people ever going to be held accountable?
No. I mean, this is sort of like a footnote.
And, you know, multiple criminal investigations
into Trump. Rudy Giuliani disbarred in some
places, all these things. This is
so comparatively minor under Obama,
it would have been absolutely and totally huge.
Oh, bam. Now they would it would be a week on Fox
News. But with Rudy and Trump, it's just like a
little footnote. It's not going anywhere, sadly.